اختراق الطائرات الروسيه المجال الجويه
لتنف 25 مره هذا الشهر وتعتبرها تهديدا
بالتصعيد
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يتفق مع نظيره
الايراني على عقد لقاء ثنائي بينهما قريبا
الفرنسيون يستعدون للخميس الاسود
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
قال قائد القوات الجويه المركزيه
الامريكيه الجنرال
ان طائرات الحربيه الروسيه اخترقت المجال
الجوي لقاعده التلف الامريكيه في جنوب
سوريا 25 مره هذا الشهر وهو ما وصفه بانه
عمل استفزازي واضاف كرينكو واتش انا
طائرات روسيه مسلحه حلقت على ارتفاع منخفض
فوق قاعده تنف كل يوم تقريبا في مارس
منتهكه بذلك اتفاقا عمره اربع سنوات بين
الولايات المتحده وروسيا مما يخاطر
بالتصعيد
وموضحا ايضا ان الروس يصرون على بقاء
الولايات المتحده بعيدا عن الوحدات البريه
الروسيه وان الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بذلك
اعتبر الجنرال الامريكيه التي خذ الروس
موقفا اكثر عدوانيه ياتي في توقيت الغريب
قد يكون من اجل الضغط على الوجود العسكري
الامريكي في سوريا
اتفق وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان على عقد لقاء مع نظيره الايراني
حسين امير عبد الله قريبا بحسب ما اوردت
وكاله الانباء السعوديه وذلك لتمهيد
الارضيه لاعاده فتح السفارات والقنصليات
بين المملكه وايران
اثر اعلان بريطانيا عن خطه لارسال ذخيره
تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المستنفد لاستخدامها في اوكرانيا اثار غضب
روسيا الرئيس روسيا بلادي هدد بالرد وقال
ان روسيا ستكون مضطره للرد في حال تزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه القذائف فيما حذر وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويغو من صدام النووي
محتمل قائلا ان خطوات اقل متبقيه قبل حدوث
صدام نووي المحتمل بين روسيا والغرب
وبدوره اكد وزير الخارجيه
ان خطوه لندن ان تمت ستصاعد الموقف الى
مستويات جديده وخطيره وستؤدي الى عواقب
وخيمه على علاقات البلدين
هذه خطوه نحو مزيد من التصعيد نحو تصعيد
خطير وكمي وصدرت تصريحات لبعض المسؤولين
الغربيين يقولون فيها انه لا يوجد شيء
مخيف في ذلك وان قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
لم تكن محظوره وانهم لا يخالفون اي
اتفاقيات لكن الجميع يتذكرون نتائج
استخدام قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم في
يوغوسلافيا والعراق عندما اصيب عشرات
الالاف من المدنيين وجنود الناتو الذين
استخدموا قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم تلك
من امر اخر يخص استخدام اليورانيوم
المستنفذ في اوكرانيا وهو تلوث الغذاء
ان استخدام ذخيره اليورانيوم المنظم سيقلل
بشكل حاد من قدره اوكرانيا على انتاج
اغذيه عاليه الجوده وغير ملوثه اذا تم
الاحتفاظ بها على الاطلاق
صلاه الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
بالبيت الابيض جون كربي انا لا تعتقد ان
ذخيره اليورانيوم المنظم تشكل تهديدا من
حيث انتشار الاشعاع وقال كربي في مؤتمر
صحفي تعليقا على توريد ذخيره اليورانيوم
والمنظم ان هذا النوع من الذخيره الشائعه
الى حد ما تم استخدامه لعده عقود
وفي مقابل الحديث عن تزويدك
موسكو هي الاخرى تتجه لتزويد الجاره
بيلاروسيا بايرانيوم لكن حقيقي
ستزودنا روسيا بالذخيره وبليورانيوم
الحقيقي اذا كان الناس في الدول الغربيه
مجانين فانهم يعطون زخما لهذه العمليه هذا
هو الشيء الاكثر فظاعه والاكثر خطوره
ولهذا السبب من الضروري الابتعاد قليلا عن
الجنون بمجرد ان تنفجر هذه الذخيره في
مواقع القوه الروسيه سيكون الرد درسا
رهيبا لكوكب الارض باكمله انها ليست فكره
جيده لبدء توجه نحو التصعيد في هذه الحرب
نحتاج للتحرك نحو حل سلمي مثلما تحدث
الرئيسان الروسي والصيني
في المقابله اكد المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه ان الجيش البريطاني
استخدم اليورانيوم المستنفذ في قذائف
خارقه للدروع لعقود كما اوضح وزير
الخارجيه
البريطانيوم المستنفذ ليس صعيدا متهما
موسكو بانها هي من تسعى للتصعيد النووي
[موسيقى]
شبح تطور الصراع في اوكرانيا لحرب النوويه
عاد للواجهه من جديد موسكو توعدت لندن
بنهايه سيئه اذا نفذت التعهد بارسال قذائف
مصنوعه من اليورانيوم المخضب الى كييف
التعهد البريطاني جلب ردود افعال الروسيه
لو تحققت فربما تنقل الصراع في اوكرانيا
الى مرحله مخيفه الرئيس الروسي حذر من ان
بلاده ستضطر الى الرد وتعمل غرب بنشر
اسلحه تحمل مكونا نوويا التحذير الروسي
شمل واشنطن رغم نفي البنتاجون اي دور
لبلاده في هذا الشان
واضح ان الغرب قرر محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكرانيا ليس فقط بالكلام بل بالافعال اذا
حصل هذا الشيء فستجد روسيا نفسها مجبره
على الرد بما يتناسب مع تزويد الغرب
لاوكرانيا باسلحه نوويه
بريطانيا من جهتها بدات غير قلقه من سيل
الوعيده الروسي بل علقت بسخريه على ما صدر
عن الكرملين ووصفته بالتضليل المقصود
واقرت الدفاع البريطانيه ان جيشها يستخدم
اليورانيوم المخطب في قبائفه الخارقه
للدروع منذ عقود هذه النوعيه من القذائف
خطيره على البيئه حيث قالت الامم المتحده
انها قد تشكل مصدر قلق بيئي في اوكرانيا
لما قد تسببه من امراض بما في ذلك خطر
الاصابه بالسرطان حنان المصري العربيه
اوضح وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان دعم
الصين سياسي والمادي لروسيا يتعرضوا مع
ويتعارضوا مع مصالح واشنطن مضيفا ان الصين
لم تتجاوز بعد الخط الاحمر لتسليم موسكو
اسلحه
على سبيل المثال الكل يراقب استجابتنا
لهذا العدوان وهو ما يجهلهم يستجيبون لهذه
الدروس انضم حلفاؤنا من اسيا بالرغم من ان
الحرب تقع على نصف الاخر من العالم
بالنسبه لهم وهذا بسبب احساسهم بالخطر
ايضا اليابان احدى الدول الرائده في
تحالفنا الداعم لاوكرانيا كما تلعب كوريا
الجنوبيه دورا هاما ايضا نفس الشيء
بالنسبه لاستراليا اذا نظرات الصين لما
يحدث بعنايه شديده فسوف تستخلص الدروس حول
قدره العالم على الوحده امام عدوان مماثل
من جانبه طلب المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه
في القضيه الاوكرانيه وتوقف عما اسماه
بالقاء اللوم على
نحث الولايات المتحده على دراسه دورها في
القضيه الاوكرانيه وتصحيح سلوكها الخاطئ
المتمثل في صب الزيت على النار والتوقف عن
القاء اللوم على الصين سنواصل الوقوف بحزم
الى جانب السلام والحوار والصواب التاريخي
والعمل بشكل بناء مع المجتمع الدولي
لمواصله دورنا في تعزيز حل سياسي للقضيه
الاوكرانيه
دعا الامين العام لحلف الناتو دول الغربيه
للاستعداد لصراع طويل الامد في اوكرانيا
حيث ان افاق تسويته لم تظهر بعد وفي
مقابله مع صحيفه البريطانيه اعتبر ان
الصراع في اوكرانيا يمكن تسميته بحرب
استنزاف مشيرا الى ان القياده الروسيه لا
تخطط للسلام مؤكدا ان الدول الغربيه بحاجه
الى زياده الطاقه الانتاجيه لتزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخيره والاسلحه الجديده منويا
الى ان معدل الاستهلاك الذخيره اعلى من
معدل الانتاج الحالي
خرج العشرات من سكان بانجيه عاصمه افريقيا
الوسطى في مسيره داعمه للصين وروسيا وشهدت
المسيره وقفه امام النصب التذكاري الذي
يخلد دور الذي لعبته قوه الجيش الحكومي
كما شهدت المسيره رفع شعارات مؤيده للصين
بعد مقتل تسعه من مواطنيها في موقع
للتعدين وسط البلاد
[موسيقى]
زياره رئيس الصينيه
الى روسيا حملت عده تفسيرات لكن الرئيس
الصيني حاول ظهورك وسيط سلام في حين كان
بوتين يعمل على تقديم نفسه بانه يحظى بدعم
احد اقوى قاده العالم
زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا فتحت الباب
امام التفسيرات والتاويلات بخصوص الهدف
منها وما ترمي اليه في جبه وسيط لحل
الصراع في اوكرانيا وحاملا خطه للسلام
هكذا حاول تقديم نفسه وهو يعلم ما يدور في
مخيله بوتين الزعيم الصيني راى في الزياره
فرصه للرد على الولايات المتحده ودعم
صورته كرجل دوله عالمي في حين كان بوتين
يحاول تقديم نفسه بانه يحظى بدعم احد اقوى
قاده العالم حتى في الوقت الذي تعمل فيه
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها على عزله
الرئيس الصيني اصطف بقوه مع روسيا ضد
الولايات المتحده لكنهم تنعى عن تقديم شيء
كان يبحث عنه بوتين الا وهو الالتزام
بشراء المزيد من الغاز فالصين تسعى لتجنب
مواجهه عقوبه اقتصاديه غربيه اكثر صرامه
يمكن ان تلحق الضرر بالاقتصاد الصيني
وحين كان شيجيبينغ يجرم بحثات مع
المسؤولين الروس في مادبه عشاء فاخره
بموسكو كان رئيس الوزراء الياباني على بعد
800 كيلومتر يضع اكليلا من الورود في بلده
بوتشا على ارواح القتل الاوكرانيين في
الحرب
فكياف تحظى بتعاطف ودعم كبير من طوكيو
القلقه مما يمكن ان يحدث لها اذا ما اقدمت
الصين على غزو تايوان هي احداث تسير في خط
متوازن غير ان زيارتي الزعيمين الاسيويين
بما لها من رمزيه لم تحدث اي فرق في ميدان
المعركه حتى الان الذي تستعر ناره ولا
تتوقف مدافعه عن القصف بلال البجدين
العربيه
قال مسؤول كوري شمالي ان الضغوط للتخلي او
تخلي بيونغيان الاسلحه النوويه ترقى الى
مستوى اعلان الحرب وجاء تصريح الذين قالته
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه الشماليه
الرسميه ردا على ذكر المندوبه الامريكيه
في الامم المتحده
نزع سلاح النووي بشكل كامل من شبه الجزيره
الكوريه
وقبل ذلك اجرت القوه الامريكيه والكوريه
الجنوبيه تدريبات مشتركه بالذخيره الحيه
في اطار المناورات العسكريه المشتركه تحت
اسم درع الحريه
[موسيقى]
في تركيا ومع اقتراب موعد الانتخابات بدا
شكل النهائي للتحالفات السياسيه يتضح اكثر
فاكثر وفي جديد تحالفات حزب مؤيد للاكراد
يقرروا دعم مرشح المعارضه الرئيسيه
واردوغان يفشل في استماله احد
في خطوه متوقعه اعلنت تحالف العمل والحريه
المعارض في تركيا عدم طرح اي مرشح رئاسي
في الانتخابات القادمه ما يعني دعما لمرشح
المعارضه الرئيسي كمال كليج داروجلو
اجرينا عمليه تقييم شامله لاعلان مرشح من
طرفنا في تحالف الحريه والعمل حيث كنا قد
اعلنا سابقا اننا سنسمي مرشحا للرئاسه بعد
تقييم الشامل نعلن رسميا باننا لن نقدم
مرشحا باسم التحالف لخوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه وسنتحمل مسؤوليتنا
التاريخيه في مواجهه نظام حكم الرجل
الواحد القائم حاليا
التحالف الذي يقوده حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المؤيد للاكراد اتخذ هذا القرار بعد
اجتماع قياده الحزب الكردي مع كيلج دار
اوغلو الاثنين الماضي حيث يسعى زعيم
المعارضه لكسب دعم الناخبين الاكراد كممثل
عن تحالف الامه المعارض او ما بات يعرف
باسم الطاوله السداسيه هذا التحالف تقدم
بدوره رسميا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
بطلب ترشيحك الجدار جلو
اتفاقنا
جئنا الى المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات مع
الاعضاء المعقرين في تحالف الامه قدمنا
طلبه ترشيح الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه
التركيه كمال
في المعسكر المقابل تبدو مهمه الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان صعبه في الانتخابات القادمه
في ظل دعم جديد تلقاه كالجدار اوكلو وايضا
ما ذكره نائب رئيس الوزراء السابق محمد
شمشك عن رفضه الانخراط في اي منصب حكومي
مع حكومه اردوغان القادمه في حال فاز
الرئيس بالانتخابات
قال انه لن يستمر في العمل السياسي ليس له
تاثير محتمل في الانتخابات برايي من جانب
المعارضه خصوصا يوجد استقطاب كبير وهم
يرون انه الوقت الانسب لرحيل اردوغان
في ضوء المستجدات الراهنه يحاول تحالف
الشعب الذي يقوده اردوغان تعزيز تحالفه
وكسب فئات جديده لذلك تحالف مع حزب الدعوه
الحره المدعوم من الاكراد المحافظين لا شك
ان هذه الانتخابات
تم حياه
او ار
دوغان لذلك من المنتظر ان نشهد في الايام
القادمه مزيدا من التحركات تجاه تيارات
سياسيه كانت على الهامش يوما ما بغيت جذب
اصواتها لاحد المرشحين زيدان زنجلو
العربيه اسطنبول
الان مشاهدينا الى لبنان حيث عادت
التحركات الى ساحه رياض الصلح احتجاجا على
عدم استقرار سعر الصرف وعدم اتخاذ الحكومه
اجراءات للحد من الانهيار وقدمه تحركات
متقاعدين الجيش وقوى الامن والجمارك الذين
حاولوا اقتحام السرايا السرايا الحكوميه
هذا اليوم
مره اخرى كان الرد على مطالب المواطنين
اللبنانيين بالقنابل المسيله
ورغم ان اكثريه المتظاهرين الذين توافدوا
الى ساحه رياض الصلح كانوا من المتقاعدين
الا ان كبر السن لم يقف عائقا امام
استخدام القوه لمنعه من اجتياز الحاجز
المؤدي الى
الحق بالطبابه والتعليم اضافه الى المطالب
المعيشيه التي زادها سوءا الانهيار
الصاروخي لليره اللبنانيه كانت الجامعه
بين مجموعات اختلفت انتماؤها
سرقونا وسرقوا جنى عمرنا ومستقبلنا
ومستقبل اولادنا هولي لصوص اللي جوا انا
جاي شاري كطالب سنوي انه اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر مدربين والوزير بعده غايب لا حلول
ولا شيء
ولا ممكن
وبالتزامن مع تحركات الشارع عقدت اللجان
النيابيه جلسه مناقشه لمسائله الحكومه
ومصرف لبنان وجمعيه المصارف عن الخطوات
التي فشلت باتخاذها
وفيما حضر ممثل عن رئيس الحكومه وحاكم
المصرف غابت جمعيه المصارف دون اي مبرر
لاحد اجوبه
انه انا اليوم اذا اضطريت اجي اذا ما رحنا
واضطريت اجي عندي عجز بالموازنه راح نكمل
طبع ميل طبعا ليره يعني بهالسهوله انكبت
بالمجلس قلت له وقفت انا اعترض قلت له اول
شيء مش هيك بيحكى عن طباعه الليره
اللبنانيه لانه واحده من الاسباب الاساسيه
انهيار هو الطباعه اسهل شي ندفع معاشات
القطاع الخاص اول شيء القطاع العام اول
شيء بتعيده هيكله القطاع العام تاني شيء
بتوقفوا التهريب بتحسنوا الايرادات
الموازنه لليوم ما تقدمت ارتفاع سعر الصرف
بنسبه 12% خلال يوم واحد حرك الشارع
اللبناني لكن الدعوات الى الاضراب لم تلقى
اذانا صغيرا ولم تلتزم الصيدليات بقرار
النقابه التي دعت الى الاغلاق احتجاجا على
عدم تسليم الشركات للادويه اما المصارف
وامام الارتفاع الصاروخي للدولار فتراجعت
عن اضرابها المفتوح الذي تشهره سلاحا في
كل مره يقف فيها القضاء بصف المدين هي
المطالب نفسها وحدت اكثر من مجموعه امام
السرايا الحكومي الذي يمثل حكومه ادارت
اذانها الصماء دون اتخاذ اي اجراء اصلاحي
يضع حدا لتعدديه سعر الصرف التي كانت سببا
اساسيا لضرب القدره الشرائيه غنوه يتيم
نشرتنا مستمره وفي بعد قليل
الرئيس التنفيذي للتيك توك ينفي مشاركه
بيانات المستخدمين مع الحكومه الصينيه
اهلا بكم من جديد ردود فعل غاضبه وممدده
بكلام رئيس الفرنسي
بعد حديثه للمره الاولى منذ ان احتجاجات
عن اصراره على تطبيق اصلاح نظام التقاعد
وبينما تتواصل الاحتجاجات في الشوارع تجهز
النقابات اليوم لاضراب عام وتظاهرات في
يوم اطلق عليه تسميه الخميس الاسود
ليس واقعيا متعجرف هذه بعض من الاوصاف
التي اجتاحت الوسط السياسي المعارضه في
فرنسا بعد كلام الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرو
وحديثه عن تمسكه بقانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد
مره جديده يتحدث رئيس الجمهوريه لكي لا
يقول شيئا ومما فهمناه نجد فقط علامات
الازدراء التقليديه التي ما يزال يرهقنا
بها الى الان
راي تتفق معه زعيمه اقصى اليمين مارين
لوبين
ايجاد الكلمات التي
توحد اليوم عزز السيد مكرون شعور لزراء
لجزء من الناس شعور الازدراء هذا انسحب
على الشارع حيث تسيطر شريحه الطلاب عليهم
منذ سته ايام ما دفع ماكرون لوصف تحركهم
بانه غير شرعي فبدات عمليات عصيان في
الجامعات وصل عددها حتى الان الى 60 جامعه
في كل فرنسا وهو تحرك انطلق من جامعه
السوربون التي طوقتها الشرطه اعلم في
العاده ننسق تحركاتنا مع النقابات لكننا
الان نتحرك من تلقاء انفسنا لان الشباب
فهموا انه اذا لم يتحرك من اجل مستقبلهم
فلن يتحرك احد من اجلهم خلال الحديث مع
ريتشي استوقف نجاره الكهل مثنيا على تحرك
الطلاب في الشارع ومعتبرا ان الشعب هو
القانون وليس ما يحاول ماكرون تطبيقه
الشباب يبعثون الخوف في قلب السلطه كبار
السن مثلي يمكن اسكاتهم لكن الشباب لا
يمكن السيطره عليهم عدم سيطره الشرطه على
احتجاجات الشباب كان واضحا من خلال تمكنهم
من تحويل ليل فرنسا الى نهار فراحوا
يشعلون الحرائق في الشوارع وهذا ليس
الافتعال الشغب كما يقولون وانما لعرقله
الشرطه التي تلهث خلفهم وتخاطر بان يكون
الوضع اسوا عندما سيجتمع هؤلاء الطلاب مع
النقابيين الذين اعدوا العده للخميس
الاسود
فدهوك العربيه باريس
رفع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدراليه الفائده
بربع نقطه مئويه لتصل الى 5% وهي الاعلى
منذ عام 2007 جاء قرار الفيدرالي متماشيا
مع اغلب توقعات المحللين على الرغم من
مطالبات عده بوقف رفع اسعار الفائده خاصه
بعد ازمه تعثر ثلاثه بنوك امريكيه الاسبوع
الماضي وقد استبدل بيان الفيدرالي عباره
رفع مستمرا للفائده بتوقعات الاعضاء ان
المزيد من التجديد في السياسه النقديه قد
يكون مناسبا للوصول بالتضخم الى مستوى
اثنين في المئه وتعليقا على الازمه
الحاليه للبنوك اشار البيان الى ان القطاع
المصرفي متين لكن الاحداث الاخيره ممكن ان
تؤدي الى تجديد في شروط الائتمان وتاثير
سلبي ايضا على النمو الا ان حجم تاثير لا
يزال غير واضح
وبعد قرار الفيدرالي اكد رئيس الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي جيرمن في المؤتمر الصحفي على
توجيهات او توجهات البنك بخفض معادلات
تضخم الى المستهدفات السابقه عند اثنين في
المئه
ان معدلات التضخم ما زالت مرتفعه كثيرا
وسوق العمل ما زالت قويه اتفاهم وزملائي
اثار التضخم السيئه على الاقتصاد واريد ان
اؤكد اننا ملتزمون وبشده بخفض معدلات
التضخم الى مستهدفاتنا عند اثنين في المئه
ضمان استقرار الاسعار هو مسؤوليه
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي وبدون استقرار
الاسعار فان الاقتصاد لن يكون جيدا لاي
احد
في النظام المصرفي امنه بعد
الاجراءات التي تم اتخاذها عقب لاضطرابته
في النظام المصرفي في الاسابيع الاخيره
مجلس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي من خلال العمل
مع وزاره الخزانه ومؤسسه التامين اتخذ
اجراءات حاسمه لحمايه الاقتصاد الامريكي
تثبت هذه الاجراءات ان جميع مدخرات
المدعين في النظامين المصرفي امنه
نفر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني تضليل
البرلمان البريطاني فيما يخص فضيحه
الحفلات لكنه عبر في الوقت نفسه عن اسفه
على انتهاك قواعد الاغلاق وقت كورونا
كان هذا خطا وانا اسف عليه بمراره اتفهم
الغضب العام ومازلت اعتذر عما حدث واتحمل
المسؤوليه الكامله ولكن كما قلت للتو فان
الغرض من هذا التحقيق ليس اعاده فتح ما
يسمى ببوابه الحزب بل الاكتشاف ما اذا كنت
قد كذبت على البرلمان ام لا وقمت بتضليل
زملائي عن عمد حول ما كنت اعرفه وامنت به
بشان تلك التجمعات عندما قلت ان القواعد
والارشادات قد تم اتباعها انا هنا لاقول
انني لم اكذب على الاطلاق
في لقاء مع تيلغراف قاله مستشار والامن
القوميه السابق جون بولتن انه يجب على
الحزب الجمهوري ان ينظف نفسه من الضرر
الذي تسبب به دونالد ترامب للحزب
لا اعلم ماذا سيكون رد ترامب لكن بعض من
القاده الجمهوريين يقولون انه لا يجب على
الناس التظاهر لصالحه اظن انه لا حدود لما
يمكن ان يفعله ترامب ويجب ان نقلق من ذلك
يجب على الحزب الجمهوري ان ينظف نفسه من
الضرر الذي تسبب به ترامب وهذه مسؤوليتنا
كجمهوريين
معهود لرئيس ليس كغيره ممن حكموا البيت
الابيض ترامب امام عقبات قضائيه لا تنتهي
في الوقت الذي ترتفع فيه حمى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التي يلعب جزء هام منها داخل
قاعه مداولاته محكمه نيويورك
قضيه واحده اعاده فتح 4000 قضيه اخرى
دونالد ترامب الرئيس الذي غادر المنصب ولم
يختفي من المشهد الاعلامي بعد اتهام ترامب
الرئيس وترامب رجل الاعمال جاء دور ترامب
المترشح ليدخل المحاكم القضيه تعود الى
عام 2016 حين اتهمت ممثله اباحيه ترامب
بشراء صمتها خوفا من فضيحه تعكر حملته
الانتخابيه القضيه كانت اقرب الى مجرد
تسويه شخصيه الا ان شهاده صديق سابق جاءت
لتغير مسار التحقيق ميشال كوهين محامي
ترامبي السابق اعترف بانه دفع شخصيا 130
الف دولار لتسويه القضيه من اموال حمله
موكله الانتخابيه ترامب لا يواجه التهمه
للمره الاولى الا انه سيقف هذه المره امام
محكمه نيويورك التي يسيطر عليها مدعي عام
الديمقراطي حتى النخاع القضيه احيت قضايا
سابقه ومعها جدوى رئيس لا تنقصه المشاكل
بعضها تم تصنيفها كتهم جنائيه وتكفي ادانه
واحده لتنصفه طموحاته السياسيه
بايادي مكبله قد يقف اول رئيس امريكي امام
محكمه جنائيه الا ان سمعه رئيس سابق لا
تهم ترامبو انصاره بقدر سمعه مترشح
للانتخابات المقبله
اتهمت ديمقراطيين باستغلال النفوذ لتسييس
القضيه وهي الحجه التي استغلها للاعب
ورقته المفضله المتمثله بدعوه الانصار
للاعتصام انصار الحزب الجمهوري وان لم يعد
ترامب يحظى بالاجماع بينهم الا انهم
اعتبره نفقا مظلما عبور ترامب منه بسلام
سيقوده الى البيت الابيض من الباب الواسع
تحديات قانونيه وقضائيه ستضع مستقبلات
السياسيه على المحكه احدها يمثل سابقه
تاريخيه في قضيه اموال الصمت التي يزعم
انه دفعها
للممثله ستورمي دانيوز لاخفاء علاقته بها
في الولايات المتحده عاصفه قضائيه وسياسيه
بطلها دونالد ترامب قرار محكمه قد يؤدي
الى اعتقال ترامب في قضيه جنائيه بخصوص
اموال الصمت التي يزعم انه دفعها للممثله
لاخفاء علاقتها به الممثله السابقه وفي
تغريدات ساخره على حسابها في تويتر كشفت
انها سترقص في الشارع في حال اودينا ترامب
ودخل السجن تغريده
طارت موجه انتقادات ضدها من قبل محبي
ترامب المشكلات القانونيه للترامب لا
تتوقف عند قضيه
بل يواجه العديد من القضايا عاليه المخاطر
ابرزها التحقيقات في جهوده لتخريب نتائج
انتخابات 2020
والتعامل مع السجلات الرئاسيه المعروفه
بقضيه وثائق مارالاغو
شدد الرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك على ان
التطبيق لم ولن يشارك بيانات المستخدمين
الامريكيين مع الحكومه الصينيه اكد ان
الشركه الام لتيك توك
ليست مملوكه لاي كيان حكومي ولن تولي
اهتماما لطلب مماثل في حال تم التقدم به
ايضا ينتظر ان يدلي الرئيس التنفيذي
بشهادته امام لجنه الطاقه والتجاره في
مجلس النواب الامريكي
انا قلقه بعض الشيء لكني لم اجري بحثا
كافيا عن الموضوع على الاطلاق ربما ينبغي
فعل ذلك
انا لست قلقا بشان بيانات الشخصيه ولكن ما
يقلقني هو ان اصحاب التيك توك في الصين
اعد الخوارزمية بحيث لن ترى ما هو سلبي في
الصين بينما في الغرب سترى اشخاصا غير
جديين
انا لا املك حسابات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لانني احب الحفاظ على خصوصيتي
لماذا سوف استخدمه اذا لم يكن لدي حساب
اضع عليه معلوماتي وعلى هاتف الذي استخدمه
للدخول على وسائل التواصل
حرب عالميه يتعرض لها تطبيق تيك توك
الصينيه الذي بات يشكل تحديا كبيرا
للحكومه الامريكيه التي تسعى لتقييده
وحظره بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي
مساعي الحظر قابلها تزايد شعبيه تيك توك
في الولايات المتحده رغم ان واشنطن كشفت
عن تتبع التطبيق لعشرات المواقع الحكوميه
والتجسس عليها وفق صحيفه
تيك توك من اكثر تطبيقات الهواتف الذكيه
الشعبيه في البلاد لدى الملايين من
الاشخاص والشركات وفق تقرير صادر عن موقع
اكسيوس الامريكي
الشركه لديها الان اكثر من 150 مليون
مستخدم في الولايات المتحده اي ما يقرب من
نصف عدد السكان في حين ان خمسه ملايين
شركه امريكيه تستخدم تطبيق تيك توك للوصول
الى عملائها ومن المتوقع ان يحقق التطبيق
اكثر من 11 مليار دولار من عائدات
الاعلانات في الولايات المتحده بحلول عام
وفي انتظار مستقبل التطبيق الذي اطلقته
الصين في عام 2016
المشرعون الذين يعارضون الحظر يطالبون
الحكومه بايجاد دليل اكثر اقناعا على ان
التيك توك يمثل تهديدا للامن القومي في
حين يقول المشرعون الذين يدعمون التحركات
ضد تيك توك ان التطبيق يمثل تهديدا
لخصوصيه بيانات المستخدم في الولايات
المتحده بسبب القوانين الصينيه التي تطلب
من الشركات مشاركه المستخدم مع الحكومه
الصينيه
قال مصدر حكومي بان وزاره داخليه
الالمانيه تشعر بالقلق ازاء العلاقات
الوثيقه بين
وشركه هواوي صينيه حيث اشار الى ان
الحكومه الالمانيه تدرس امكانيه حظر
مكونات معينه من شركه هواوي الصينيه في
خطوه يحتمل ان تكون مهمه لمعالجه المخاوف
الامنيه ومنع فقدان الرياده التكنولوجيه
جاهد بعد تصريحات لوزير الاقتصاد الالماني
الذي اكد بان ضوابط الصادرات الالمانيه
تجري مراجعتها في ضوء تطورات التكنولوجيه
الجديده
تحضيرات امميه من ان العالم يواجه ازمه
مياه عالميه بسبب ارتفاع عدد السكان
وتطورات الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه وتغير
انماط الاستهلاك
ازمه مياه عالميه الوحوش الافق
تحذير اممي من ازمه مياه عالميه وشيكا نحو
26% من سكان العالم بلا ماء نظيف
ولمعالجه مشكله توفير المياه النظيفه
لجميع السكان بحلول عام 2030 ستكون هناك
حاجه الى ما يصل لترليون دولار سنويا
الاستهلاك العالمي للمياه ارتفع بنحو واحد
في المئه سنويا على مدى السنوات الاربعين
الماضيه وسط توقعات بان ينمو بالمعدل نفسه
خلال الثلاثين عاما المقبله لاسباب عده
اهمها زياده النمو السكاني وانماط
الاستهلاك والتنميه الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه
فتحت الحدائق في العاصمه اليابانيه طوكيو
وتحديدا في مدينتي كيوتو واوساكا ابوابها
امام السكان والسائحين لرؤيه مهرجان ازهار
الكرز الشهير المهرجان هو تقليدي تقليد
ياباني وذلك للاحتفال بحلول موسم الربيع
حيث اعلنت وكاله الارصاد الجويه اليابانيه
قبل اسبوع ان ازهار الاشجار بدات في
التفتح في طوكيو وذلك قبل عشره ايام من
الموعد المعتاد وقبل سته ايام من العام
الماضي
بسبب المقالات المتداوله التي تفيد بانه
لم يحن وقت موسم ورده الساكورا كنا خائفين
من اننا لن نراها لكن بعد رؤيتها شعرنا
بالسعاده والفرح
بالنسبه لي كانت رائعه انتظرنا وقتا طويلا
لم نكن نعرف ما نتوقعه وبالتاكيد كانت
الرحله مختلفه لا مثيل لها
انها جميله ومميزه للغايه ليس لدينا هذا
النوع من الاشجار في الدنمارك والجو بارد
جدا وغائم هناك
النشره الى العناوين
واشنطن تاكيد اختراق الطائرات الروسيه
المجال الجوي للتنف 25 مره هذا الشهر
وتعتبرها تهديدا بالتصعيد
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يتفق مع نظيره
الايراني على عقد لقاء ثنائي بينهما قريبا
تظاهرات ليليه في باريس
يتحدى المتظاهرين بتطبيق قانون التقاعد
نهايه العام
اشكركم على حسن المتابعه مشاهدينا الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]